[Music]  America's Got Talent winner Neal Boyd  has died he can confirm the AGT season  three champion died on Sunday at age 42  a spokesperson for the Scott County  coroner's office tells ET Neal was  battling some pretty major health  problems he was in heart failure kidney  failure and he had some liver problems  he died at his mother's house in  Sikeston Missouri Singh the first time  in parade  she's everything to me the opera singer  won America's Got Talent in 2008 and  released his first album my American  dream the following year former AGT  Judge Piers Morgan took to Twitter to  express his sadness at the news sharing  this photo with Boyd writing lovely guy  with a wonderful voice rest in peace  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Applause]